sie sehen nun die Neujahrsansprache des
Bundeskanzlers
liebe Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger heute
Nacht geht ein schweres Jahr zu Ende in
keinem Jahresrückblick fehlen die Bilder
des 24 Februar als im Morgengrauen die
ersten russischen Raketen in Kiew Krake
von Odessa und anderen ukrainischen
Städten einschlugen
Putin führt ein imperialistischen
Angriffskrieg mitten in Europa
diese zeitenwände stellt auch uns und
unser Land auf einer harte Probe viele
machen sich Sorgen wegen des Kriegs wir
fühlen mit den Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainern die selbst am Tagen wie heute
keine Ruhe haben vor den russischen
Bomben und Raketen und wir alle spüren
die Folgen dieses Kriegs auch in unserem
Alltag beim Einkaufen im Supermarkt an
der Tankstelle oder wenn wir die Strom
oder Gasrechnung bezahlen und doch
handelt die Geschichte dieses Jahres
2022 nicht allein von Krieg Leid und
Sorge
Putin hat die Ukraine eben nicht in
wenigen Tagen überrannt wir geplant
hatte ganz im Gegenteil tapfer
verteidigen die Ukrainerinnen und
Ukraine ihre Heimat auch dank unserer
Hilfe und wir werden die Ukraine weiter
unterstützen
die Europäische Union und die NATO
stehen nicht gespalten da wie in manch
früherer Krise sondern so geeint wie
lange nicht
und wir in Deutschland sind nicht
eingeknickt als uns Russland im Sommer
den Gashand zugedreht hat weil wir uns
nicht erpressen lassen
auch das liebe Mitbürgerinnen und
Mitbürger ist für mich die Geschichte
des Jahres 2022
sie handelt von Zusammenhalt und Stärke
und ja auch von Zuversicht
an dieser Geschichte haben sie alle
mitgeschrieben überall in unserem Land
in Wilhelmshaven an der Nordsee zum
Beispiel vor zwei Wochen hat dort die
höchstexperanza festgemacht ein
schwimmendes Terminal das uns künftig
mit Flüssiggas versorgt
das neue Terminal und die dafür nötigen
Leitung haben unsere Ingenieurinnen und
Facharbeiter nicht einmal 200 Tagen
gebaut
schon in den kommenden Wochen und
Monaten gehen weitere flüssiggast
terminals in Betrieb in Lubmin in Stade
in Brunsbüttel damit machen wir unser
Land und Europa dauerhaft unabhängig von
russischem Gas und zugleich kommen wir
so durch diesen Winter übrigens auch
dank gut gefüllter gastspeicher und weil
wir gemeinsam in den vergangenen Monaten
Energie eingespart haben
das bleibt auch in den kommenden Monaten
wichtig und dafür möchte ich Ihnen schon
heute ausdrücklich danken
die Geschichte des Jahres 2022 handelt
von einem Land in dem wir uns für andere
einsetzen von 29 Millionen freiwilligen
und ehrenamtlichen Land auf und Land ab
von dem überwältigen Mitgefühl und der
Hilfsbereitschaft mit denen so viele von
ihnen den geflüchteten aus der Ukraine
begegnen in Köln habe ich Frauen und
Männer getroffen die ukrainische
Kriegsflüchtlinge versorgen unter den
neuankömmlichen war damals eine ganze
Frauenfußballmannschaft einige mit ihren
Kindern nicht nur er Hab und Gut mussten
diese Frauen in der Ukraine zurücklassen
sondern auch ihre Ehemänner Freunde
Väter und Brüder
dass wir helfen in solcher not das
zeichnet uns aus das macht unser Land zu
einem menschlichen Land
an der Geschichte unseres Landes in
dieser Zeitenwende schreiben auch
diejenigen mit die sich für unsere
Sicherheit einsetzen zum Beispiel bei
der Polizei oder bei der Bundeswehr in
unseren Feuerwehren oder bei den
Rettungsdiensten
auf einem Truppenübungsplatz in Bergen
in der Lüneburger Heide habe ich erlebt
wie gewissenhaft unsere Soldaten
Soldaten trainieren um unser Land unsere
Freunde und Alliierten gegen alle
Bedrohungen zu verteidigen
dafür verdienen sie höchsten Respekt und
unsere Dankbarkeit
2022 habe ich Deutschland als ein Land
erlebt das innovativ ist
in Schwarzheide etwa in der Lausitz dort
haben wir junge FacharbeiterInnen
Techniker voller Enthusiasmus gezeigt
wie Sie künftig alte Batterien recyceln
die wir für Elektroautos nutzen werden
oder in dem kleinen Ort Allendorf in
Nordhessen da entwickeln unsere
Ingenieuren und Ingenieure moderne
hocheffiziente luft-
und ich denke an all diejenigen die
solche Geräte dann montieren und
einbauen in München habe ich mich mit
einigen von ihnen getroffen mit
Handwerkerinnen und Handwerkern
Elektronikern
Schornsteinfegerinnen und Installateuren
sie haben mir gesagt wir sind die
Problemlöser wenn es um den Klimaschutz
und um die Energiewende geht
und das stimmt auch sie sorgen mit ihrer
Arbeit dafür dass unser Land eine gute
Zukunft hat
wie wir Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger
Orte wie München und Allendorf wie Köln
und Schwarzheide Bergen und
Wilhelmshaven gibt es überall in unserem
Land
Orte wo man hart arbeitet und tüftelt wo
alle mit anpacken und wo man
zusammenhält und füreinander da ist
im Vereinen und Bürgerinitiativen bei
der Freiwilligen Feuerwehr in
Krankenhäusern und Pflegeheimen in
Schulen und Kindergärten auf Dorf und
Stadtfesten
das ist Deutschland zu Beginn dieses
neuen Jahres ein starkes Land ein Land
das mit Tatkraft und Tempo an einer
guten sicheren Zukunft arbeitet ein Land
das sich unterhagt gerade in schweren
Zeiten ein Land in dem wir niemanden
zurücklassen egal ob in der Stadt oder
auf dem Land ob alt oder jung ob gut
situiert oder weniger wohlhabend ob hier
geboren oder erst später hierher
gekommen
damit alle in Deutschland mit den
gestiegenen Preisen zurechtkommen haben
wir im vergangenen Jahr große
entlastungspakete geschnürt morgen am
Neujahrstag treten weitere Neuerungen in
Kraft
das Wohngeld das allen hilft die für
geringe Einkommen arbeiten gehen oder
die von einer kleinen Rente leben ein
deutlich höheres Kindergeld und ein
höherer Kinderzuschlag so dass unsere
Familien mehr im Portemonnaie haben
Steuerentlastung insgesamt 19 Milliarden
Euro für die vielen die jeden Tag
arbeiten und sich anstrengen hier in
unserem Land und schließlich Deckeln wir
die Kosten für Strom Gas und Fernwärme
liebe Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger unser
Zusammenhalt ist unser größtes Pfund
darum wünsche ich uns am Beginn dieses
neuen Jahres eines bleiben wir dem Weg
treu den wir im vergangenen Jahr
eingeschlagen haben gehen wir in mutig
weiter vor allem aber halten wir auch im
kommenden Jahr zusammen zwischen München
und Wilhelmshaven zwischen Schwarzheide
in der Lausitz und Köln im Rheinland
wo immer sie heute Nacht das alte Jahr
verabschieden und vielleicht mit ihrer
Familie mit Freundinnen und Freunden auf
das neue anstoßen
ich wünsche Ihnen von ganzem Herzen dass
dieses neue Jahr für Sie ein gutes Jahr
wird
zum neuen Jahr sprach der Bundeskanzler